[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and welcome to our
weekly anime news cast the links are in
the description recommendations go in
the comments now right off the bat we
actually have some pretty big news for
fans of Code Geass this past week
Funimation announced the official
english-language dub of Akito the exiled
the official Code Geass OVA the octo the
exiled OVA first aired in Japan several
years ago and fans were beginning to
think that there would never be an
english-language dub and the reason I
think that they're making this dub now
is because of all the hype for Code
Geass season 3 ever since we learned
that there would be a sequel of Code
Geass there has been a lot of hype a lot
of merchandise has been selling and I
think finally Funimation realized that I
would be more than profitable to make an
english-language dub unfortunately we
still have no specific information about
the Code Geass sequel release date
however here at anime oper we are
checking daily so be sure to subscribe
and stay tuned because we will let you
know as soon as we learn something new I
want to give a quick thank you to the SS
ultimate Goku and crobat God for first
bringing up this information about the
dub in our discord server and I also
want to thank Niklas MC HD for linking
to the official Funimation tweet again
into this court and speaking of the
discord server that is also the best
place to catch new uncensored episodes
of Anna Mac after dark but on a serious
note here at Anime uproar we have had a
lot of new content come out in the last
few weeks including two major Code Geass
videos one video is about every known
Geass power and how it works and the
other one is top 10 facts about c2 so be
sure to check those out the links are in
the description last week we also hosted
a special episode of rant cafe in which
we roasted that anime snobs book and
that was a lot of fun it was the biggest
rant Kafei yet so you can check that out
as well link in the description and on
top of that just yesterday I released my
response to the whole dizzy bro anime
community controversy drama whatever you
want to call it so if that is something
you're interested in you can check out
that video as well Anna Mack after dark
baby in other big news studio bones
announced last week that they're going
to be producing on brand new
film trilogy for the anime el deca seven
or Eureka Seven if you want to pronounce
it wrong the first film is scheduled to
come out sometime in 2017 with the other
two coming out in 2018 and 2019
respectively this trilogy is expected to
feature new footage re-recorded lines
and a brand-new never before seen ending
and all of this is huge and great news
for Erika Simon fans of course however
unfortunately I am NOT one of you I was
not a fan of the show however I'm happy
for you and one thing that I forgot to
mention last week is that my boy cyanide
blizzard better known as stable [ __ ]
recently released the season finale of
his first impression series in this
episode the enemy that is being reviewed
is hand Shakers and this video actually
features the takeover by the crew of
Rand cafe including yours truly I had a
great time collaborating with cyanide
blizzard on this one it was a great
video be sure to check it out I mean of
course it was great I was in it and
speaking of the rant cafe crew this
Thursday at 5 p.m. Eastern Standard Time
we're going to have a special guest
joining Rand cafe 2spooky will be
joining us this week so be sure to check
it out and while we're on the subject of
2spooky this week he released a video
about 10 things you probably didn't know
about Saitama from one punch man now
here in anime upper we recently upload a
video on everything we know so far about
one punch man season 2 and we are
waiting for a release date sometime soon
so I think 2spooky released this video
at just the right time and features some
great facts about Saitama just be warned
there are a lot of spoilers and also
this week our trusty Lord Chancellor
from the discord server vector Maximus
uploaded an actual video on his YouTube
channel after like two months
this video was a livestream of him
playing the fate ex Atilla games so if
you want to check that out the link is
in the description and tell him I sent
ya cuz I bet he won't watch this video
and my favorite a MV for this week was
an a me called forever by the anime Bros
this MV features a combination of a
whole bunch of different anime including
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood Gurren
Lagann and the seven deadly sins and it
is really well done it looks amazing
be sure to check it out and that is it
for this week guys if you enjoyed
videos be sure to LIKE and subscribe and
until next time see ya space Cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]